on serait déjà là si romane se
trimbalait pas dans un lingot sur
roulette je vais t'éblouir frérot
les portes sont verrouillées c'est un
piège c'est une bombe alors les nulsent
quoi le Vatican
[Musique]
le grand homme doretto tu vois si tu
avais pas été au volant à l'époque
je serai pas devenu l'homme que je suis
et maintenant je suis l'homme qui va
briser ta famille
petit à petit le diable arrive
[Musique]
j'étais sûr que tu viendras me voir
est-ce que je te propose c'est qu'on se
tire dessus les uns les autres on va
régler ça
[Applaudissements]
on va creuser des tombes
j'ai aucune confiance en toi et t'es pas
sur ma liste de Noël
la cavalerie s'amène
on a besoin de flingue et de voiture
oh là là
tu aimes les surprises
la partie est finie d'homme tu as perdu
c'est ta dernière course
tu devrais mettre ta ceinture